Speaker 1: Well, as we increasingly suspected,
the leak of the Supreme Court Roe v Wade decision
increasingly appears to have been leaked by
right wingers in order to ensure that Roe v
Wade was overturned. We have a new report from
Rolling Stone. It is absolutely fascinating and
we are going to talk about it. But let me kind
of reset the story for you. When that decision
leaked, there was the immediate reaction
from the right that this was a left winger
who leaked the decision to pressure justices
to vote to preserve Roe v Wade in order to
intimidate them. And much of the reason for that
was that left wingers were rightly outraged that
the Supreme Court planned to overturn Roe v Wade.
So the right said it was a left winger who did the
leaking. We've got to investigate it. We've got
to figure out who it is. People should be fired,
disbarred, if they're lawyers, whatever. Now, I
took the approach of if we're just speculating,
could have been a left winger, could have
been a right winger. There were two scenarios.
One potential scenario would be the leaker was on
the left, knew that the draft would overturn Roe v
Wade, and thought that by leaking it, it might
generate a pressure campaign to get a Supreme
Court justice or two to change their minds and
vote to preserve Roe v Wade. Just as plausibly,
the leaker could have been a right winger who
was aware that while this draft would have
overturned Roe v Wade, the February draft that
was leaked in, you know, a few months after that,
they may have known that within the court there
may have been justices changing their minds. And
the idea was to leak the draft, to publicize who,
as of February, planned to overturn Roe v Wade,
to make it difficult for them to change their
minds. These were the two speculative scenarios.
And over time, as Republicans stop
talking about investigating the leaker,
as we heard from longtime Supreme Court
reporters, that within the Supreme Court,
the belief was actually that the leaker was a
right winger. I started to be of the mindset
that the leaker was probably a right winger. Well,
we now know from a new report that that appears to
be correct. John Roberts was lobbying Kavanaugh
to save Roe. Then the draft opinion leaked. A new
report says the leak, which conservatives insist
was the work of a rogue liberal, actually helped
get Roe overturned. This was exactly the opinion
that I told you months ago was the most likely
immediately after the draft Supreme Court decision
was released. Conservatives began bleeding about
how the leak was the work of a nefarious liberal
cleric who wanted to put the opinion out to
pressure the court's conservatives to change their
minds. It's possible that that's what happened,
but if so, publicizing the draft had the opposite
effect, according to a new report from CNN. Per
the report, the leak of the draft decision foiled
that Chief Justice Roberts attempts to persuade
Brett Kavanaugh to act as Roe's saving vote.
Sources told CNN Roberts continued to try and
sway the junior justices even after the leak of
the opinion, despite public and private pressure
from conservatives for the court to solidify
its decision. Roberts overtures this spring,
particularly to Kavanaugh, raised fears among
conservatives and hopes among liberals that the
chief would change the outcome in the most closely
watched case in decades. Now, you might remember,
Roberts ultimately voted to uphold the Mississippi
law. That was disputed, but he did a separate
concurrence disagreeing with the decision to
strike down Roe. So I know a lot of you might be
saying, but, David, the math doesn't work because
Roberts did vote to uphold Dobbs. And the belief
is based on what he wrote and based on everything
that's being reported. Roberts wanted to uphold
Dobbs, but still maintain Roe v Wade and
was working on Kavanaugh to do the same.
This is exactly what it increasingly seemed like
within about eight or ten days of the leaked
decision. And this thinking provides support
for the belief that the leaker was a right wing
staffer. They wanted to prevent Brett Kavanaugh
from defecting. That's fundamentally what it is,
and this is probably why we never heard it. How
is the search going for the real killer? O.J.,
what do we know? Right. It's the same type of
thing. We're going to investigate it. Oh, wait. It
was one of ours. Yeah, let's just never
mention that investigation again. And it's
very funny and also kind of disturbing how
in the days immediately following the leak,
everybody was saying the right wing
operatives were saying, what a travesty,
what a miscarriage of justice. This is criminal.
People need to be charged. People need to be
disbarred. These left wingers leaking this stuff
and then we never hear about it again. And to be
perfectly frank, the dead giveaway was that
the right and conservative media went silent
about the investigation and the leaker. About
a week or ten. Days after the leak took place.
Somebody maybe tipped them off and said,
don't even talk about this. The leaker was
one of ours or not even just don't talk about
this. Don't say more about the investigation.
And that's what the report is. And it's exactly
what we and many of you believed at the time.